the dipper area manhunt for teenagers
said to be obsessed with the Columbine
massacre revived fears of a new attack
at the school in the nearly 20 years
since 12 students and a teacher were
killed at Columbine 122 people have died
in mass school shootings across this
country Barry Petersen got rare access
to security preparations designed to
prevent another shooting at Columbine
he's at the school in Littleton Colorado
very good morning good morning well we
were the first Network News team allowed
inside this very sophisticated simulator
it's used to train first responders
including those who work in the school
district that includes Columbine and it
is frightening Lee real fair warning
these images may be disturbing to some
people I have people see even in a
simulator five suspects down at medical
on standby school protective officer
michael ortega took me into a hell we
increasingly face a school shooting I
got a quarter here I got a corner here
adrenalin pumping he faces life or death
suspect down suspect down shots fired
shots fired I need backup now
second suspects second moment you get
the call that's the moment you start
planning what you're gonna do yes yes
and because in a situation like this
where it's an active shooter I could be
going in alone that's the whole purpose
of an active shooter situation is to get
that and stop the threats that's how
much tactics have changed because of
Columbine in that era police waited for
a SWAT team and in those minutes the
shooters kept killing now in Colorado
officers are told going alone get the
shooter Goodspeed they've talked in the
hallways of this former elementary
school under the watchful eye of Arvada
police sergeant michael touched them
good movement can I make a difference
can I save lives and then finally is it
worth it and you got to put yourself in
the mindset that you're going to go
forward you're gonna save innocent lives
this classroom with its eerie cutouts of
kids some with guns is part of that
training overseen by John McDonald we're
trying to train
to respond to any threat being of any
age he is executive director for school
safety in the district that includes
Columbine we got today
today there are cameras everywhere
monitored 24/7 doors that can be locked
remotely armed officers inside the
schools we can pick up a suspect on
camera they can send me a picture and so
as we arrive we don't have to try and
figure out a bad guy as a good guys on
that day police were happened because
they had no idea of the school layout
maps and blueprints no it's important
that
so now MacDonald carries a blueprint
every school in his district there's a
state website called safe to tell for
anonymous tips and social media is
monitored for any suspicious posts if
you say you're gonna kill us I believe
you if you say you're gonna blow us up
we believe you we are gonna do
everything in our power to make sure
that that doesn't happen what does it
feel like when you're here what do you
think about I think about all the
students who were just like me
who had their lives taken away from them
at the memorial dedicated to those who
were killed we talked with Columbine
seniors Rachel hill and Teebs
Simon's born after the shooting they
grew up in a time when active shooter
drills start in kindergarten do you feel
safer being in this school because you
know about that or does it just make you
scared because you've got to go through
all these drills I feel extraordinarily
safe at home buying the drills aren't
overkill
I think it's made it easier to really
focus on school because I'm not worried
about being the victim of something
both favor second Amendment rights
Teague's favors arming teachers I don't
think that every teacher should be
allowed to have guns but I definitely do
believe that that could be an option but
Rachel believes it could put teachers at
risk and so I think if someone goes into
school and they see a person with a gun
they don't know if they're good or bad
they don't know if they've killed others
they're gonna shoot no one imagined the
mass murder of a school shooting could
happen here now with precautions and
training Columbine may be one of the
safest schools in America
we talked to a teacher who was here 20
years ago when the shooting broke out he
ran down the hallway yelling at students
to evacuate and mostly they just gave
him blank stares now the students who go
to the school are trained not just to
respond but to respond instantly John
Mary thank you
what an amazing piece that was chilling
to watch those those simulations
it's a terrible sign of the times that
kids now have to be trained in school
shootings little kids
yeah kindergarten it's it's but it is of
it is where we are today and very
important think about parkland what
actually I do